please welcome sharon stone
oh my gosh sharon how
are you well i am actually really great
and we're back to school pretty smoothly
because my kids are 14
15 and 20 so we're in high school and
college over here so it's
pretty it's going pretty well um
so far i have to say i'm now hearkening
back
to being seven years old and looking up
at you
with these marveling eyes you were
someone that i really looked up to
um and at the same time you didn't treat
me like a little
kid which i didn't feel like a little
kid at seven
as lovely and as incredibly helpful as
you were to me
going on my first movie and i turn
around and there's this little little
girl telling me don't worry i learned
all your lines
so if you don't know anything just look
at me and i'll help you
and i was new in the business and you
were the first time i'd met a child
actor
and um you know i've always had a
special place in my heart for you
and i admire you
more than i can say for the way you
sorted yourself out and the way you
stayed such a good
kind and tender person well thank you
and you're associated to me with a
feeling
and it's a very positive strong
you always exude like strength
that's to me a common thread in your
work and you as a person
i feel like you were born a woman like
i've never i knew you when i was seven
years old and we were both really young
but you have like always been like
the epitome of a woman and by the way
damn woman
what fountain what devil soul selling
what suits there what are you
how do you look the exact same you
are like just an amazing woman
meow well i think as we grow older we
have to negotiate
you know with mother nature and with
time
and i think you know when we're young
and we're going crazy and we're
experimenting and we're so curious
and i think as we get older there are
things that we should and should not do
to our body and i think that there are
certain things that
are fun when we're young and are
damaging as we get older
okay what if you've like lived a life of
debauchery like i have
because i did everything i ever wanted
to i was immortal
and i literally just treated my body
like a compost and not the natural kind
now i'm much more about balance
and longevity i'm not worried about the
future
i'm i'm interested in the natural
progression of things
i think i've always had a strength
see that's the thing i'm 62. and i think
god you look like you're
30. you t you look very very young and i
think the thing is
as we get older we have to say you know
it's the debauchery is not great for
a growing older body yeah and when i got
to be 40 i thought
oh look i am going to get older so how
do i want to get older
and i thought i'd like to get older like
a dancer
i always thought that the women who were
dancers aged so beautifully
and they had great posture and they
moved beautifully and they still
could move right and so i thought i have
to behave more like a dancer
and i'm gonna have to eat better i'm
just thoughtful about what i put in my
body
and i'm thoughtful about the way i treat
my body so that i don't
um so that i get to keep it do you think
that what we say to our kids about
being pretty on the inside um i feel
like your insides also
come out with you you just hate your
vote i drilled down on that with my kids
i mean i you know my kids we each have
certain things we each have
issues in ourselves and i say you know
you might have at any given point
one of my kids when they were in about
the third or fourth grade
they wanted to do whatever everybody
else was doing
well everybody's doing that and we
talked a lot about
what it meant to be a roof jumper if
everybody else jumps off the roof
why would you jump off the roof you know
i was what it means to be the first
by the way yeah and you were generally
pretty successful and i was the person
who never jumped off the roof
because i was so uptight about it and
it's funny because you would you have to
sort of
that it would be the opposite you were
so bold
putting yourself out there like i feel
like you were always
like possessed that incredible charisma
and strength
but i'm more strategic i'm more of a
logic
person and a strategy person i mean even
when i wanted basic instinct
i decided i was going to do a playboy
article
specifically because i wanted to get
this film basic instinct
i didn't realize what would happen when
i did the film
i did think it was the part right part
for me but i didn't unders
and i knew what i had to do to get it i
i didn't
have enough perspective to realize what
was gonna happen
you've always been so riveting to watch
in everything that you do i was seven
years old riveted watching you you were
like the most but i wish that i was
funnier like you
i wish that i had that kind of ability
to go just be funny like you're so
funny you're so thank you
well and just banging out comedy after
comedy after comedy it's just
awesome because i would be literally in
a straight jacket
if i didn't have comedy humor was my
out and it was my out of pain
it was also my end to what was made life
worth living
for me and it's a coping mechanism i
love when something really tragic
happens
i sometimes burst out laughing it's like
it's just like
at the most inappropriate times i go to
these really dark places
speaking of that's an amazing segue to
ratched
i it's so compelling and
everybody's freaking kind of still got
smack
okay oh my god it's so incredible what
i mean i think everybody's excited for
every aspect of it but it's so stylized
and so
performance driven and so
character-driven
that even though the sets are
extraordinary what's happening within
the framework of organizations
are just extraordinary and you are so
amazing in it so i'm so happy that
ratchet is just
this phenomenon it's really thrilling
it's really thrilling to see what
uh what can happen and it was really
exciting to work with all these women
and see their
and men and see their great performances
i mean just
just great i mean i i had a great time
i it was really fun and it's fun to work
for them i have to say i
had a good time everybody ratched is
available now
on netflix
[Music]